hi I'm Annie whoo and I'm a mathematics
teacher it is so easy to get caught up
in the challenges of our job and the the
the big things that's kind of like oh my
goodness how are we going to make a
change in society
we think about you know the cultural
view of mathematics that I'm trying to
work with and against and that often can
be quite overwhelming when you think
about it
but for me what always brings me back is
that I've had this opportunity to go all
around the country and have the
privilege of working with thousands of
people around Australia and see the
amazing work they're doing
mathematically someone said to me once
our you know we always knew you were
destined for bigger things then you know
just in the classroom and I always have
to stop them and correct them and say
there is nothing bigger than working
with one student having a deep you know
life-changing impact on the way that
they view themselves and the world
around them and mathematics can do that
I miss there are few things that have
such emotional decisiveness on the way
someone thinks about them is a my my
intelligent or am I not often it's
whether they they got mathematics or
they did it and I think that is such a
powerful experience both positively and
natively that mathematics teachers get
to have we need to recognize what a
personal impact is there but often we
don't recognize